nous sommes dans un lieu magnifique
pourquoi avez vous choisi la pyramide du
louvre la commission chargée de
l'organisation de ces émissions a donné
autorisation de sortie aux différents
candidats et donc au lieu d'aller dans
les studios ont choisi le lieu de sa
préférence j'ai hésité il ya d'autres
lieux que j'aime bien entendu et là
c'était pratique c'est beau et c'est
significatif d'une évolution de l'art
contemporain d'un an tradition je dirais
pas éternel mais plusieurs fois
séculaire c'est à la fois le passé il
est demain et c'est un grand projet au
travers de cette pyramide c'est le
branle lourd dans l'ambition d'en faire
vraiment le plus grand et le plus
commode musées du monde d'un symbole
pour vous de la vie et de la culture
oui je crois rêver je n'ai rien inventé
ce musée là dans des lieux qui signifie
vraiment les origines de l'histoire de
france c'est tout près c'est derrière
moi là que se trouve à quelques dizaines
de mètres les premières fondations de la
tour 2 ouvre philippe auguste le début
du xiiie siècle
ça va faire bientôt sept siècles et
maintenant il faut donner à la fin d'une
autre et au siècle prochain la modernité
nécessaire
photo même temps que les beautés de la
culture soit accessible à qui veux tu en
user oui si vous avez toujours été
fidèle à cette thèse que toutes les
cultures
le problème c'est qu'il n'ya peut être
pas nécessairement ni urgence de la
culture par rapport à la santé l'emploi
ni égalité d'accès vers jean yves en or
il ya urgence
il ya urgence la culture comme du reste
car finalement c'est le ciment c'est le
liant qui fait la réalité d'un peuple
une culture ambiante chacun le sent bien
mais y'a pas accès il ya là une
inégalité grave à cela que je voudrais
remédier c'est à dire des ports par
rapport aux nantis en avoir le jeune
parlons
mais tout simplement des femmes par
rapport aux hommes indiscutablement les
inégalités sociales pèsent lourd sur
l'inégalité d'accès à la culture
malgré le chômage malgré les embûches
les préjugés les tentations de se
raccrocher au passé nous voyons se
dessiner les lignes de force d'une autre
société et d'une autre manière de vivre
à partir de là je m'arrêterai un instant
sur ce que l'on appelle trop couramment
et trop vite pour une femme le droit de
choisir choisir de travailler à temps
plein ou à temps partiel
choisir de ne pas travailler pour élever
ses enfants
tout va
à
la famille demeure qu'il faut jamais ce
lien entre les générations à partir
duquel les autres lien ce vote a redit
qu'elle est plus que j'aime est chargé
il désire de bonheur ressentent les
artères la politique démographique doit
prendre en compte ces réalités faire en
sorte que puissent d'être tous les
enfants désirés et qu'ils puissent
grandir avec des chances aussi égal que
possible
tout ceci est très beau mais dans la
réalité
pauvre femme elles sont très loin je
crois que la coutume délibéré et on a
raison les inégalités qui frappent la
société française telle couche sociale
par rapport à tel autre mais la plus
grave des inégalités c'est celle qui
sait pas les femmes des hommes surtout
les dans tous les domaines la formation
dans tous les domaines d'aborder le
point de départ les petites filles et
jeunes filles ne sont pas formés au
métier qu'elles feront elles n'auront
donc pas les qualifications nécessaires
pour ensuite lorsqu'elles seront une
profession disposer ou des
qualifications ou des salaires qui
correspondent aux qualifications peuple
inégalités et les déjà dès l'origine
lorsqu'elles sont au travail
lorsqu'elles ont un emploi elles sont
généralement les emplois sous-payés
puisqu'elles sont généralement moins
qualifiés et à qualification égale c'est
l'inégalité professionnelle car par
exemple toujours un qualification
capacité égale la moyenne des salaires
ou des traitements les femmes et de 15%
inférieur au salaire des hommes on parle
les smicards c'est un terme que je
n'aime pas mais enfin les travailleurs
qui sont au smic des trois quarts de ces
travailleurs sont des femmes
c'est à dire que l'inégalité du point de
départ d l'information sur le débouché
de l'école l'université sur la
profession marque une femme pour la
durée de sa vie une graves inégalités
jusqu au chômage comment ce petit qui
étant déjà les moins chères les moins
bien payés ils sont quand même plus vite
touché par le chômage tout de suite
lorsque l'on se défait une partie du
personnel
ap les femmes en majorité les femmes
sont des chômeurs de plus longue durée
et comme elle avait les salaires les
plus faibles les allocations qu'elle
reçoit sont aussi des plus faibles c'est
un circuit vraiment un circuit infernal
des com'zones à moins bonne formation
elles retrouveront plus difficilement
plus difficilement alors voilà j'estime
que c'est une des luttes principal qui
doit être mené les problèmes familiaux
nous en ferons peut-être écouter leurs
dents les inégalités en soi tellement
parler tout de suite il ya la charge des
enfants
la charge des enfants en quoi notre
société est-elle organisée pour que la
femme souffre moins de cette inégalité
qui peut être corrigée qui doit être
corrigé que nous corrigerons mais pour
l'instant c'est comme ça est ce qu'il ya
les équipements dans les grands
ensembles collectifs
est ce qu'il y a les crèches pour garder
des enfants
est ce qu'il y a les rythmes scolaires
qui permettent à la mère de famille et
les rythmes de travail pour elle-même
qui puisse accorder les besoins qui sont
contradictoires
donc que ce soit sur ce terrain ou sur
un autre
la plus grande inégalité celle dont on
parle le moins à laquelle on s'est
attaqué la loi roudy de 1983 avait tout
de même fait réaliser un grand progrès
mais elle est restée depuis quelques
temps lettre morte
plus grandes inégalités la plus cruelle
c'est celle qui sépare deux femmes et
les hommes je t elle dire lorsqu'on
l'oubli depuis soit vous ne pouvez pas
empêcher que les femmes seront bien
obligés de s'arrêter pour donner
naissance à leur enfant et là ça restera
d'inégalités oui c'est même on peut mais
les erreurs à ce moment là les deux
thèmes
c'est la plus grave des inégalités c'est
en même temps la plus grande perte de
liberté parce qu'une femme qui travaille
chez elle et qui travaille extérieur
qu'est la charge d'une famille et le
travail en moyenne deux projets
statistics officiel une soixantaine
d'heures par semaine
et comme on vient de le dire
ne reçoit pas le concours de la société
lagarde pour les soeurs je vais
continuer la liberté elle-même pour une
femme de choisir c'est pour moi une
règle fondamentale tout être doit
pouvoir être libre de son choix
est ce que véritablement une femme
chargée de famille est libre de choisir
son travail et ses devoirs
chez millions nom est l'un des objectifs
politiques dans le vrai sens du terme
dans le bon sens du terme de tout
responsable de la nation c'est
précisément de parvenir à faire que la
femme soit libre de son choix nous
considérer pardonnez moi vous considérez
que c'est le rôle du président de la
république quel qu'il soit de
s'intéresser à la façon dont la femme
peut être libre de son choix des femmes
toutes femmes tous les jours libre de
son choix et du miro les choix soient
pas avoir eu par exemple au troisième
enfant restée chez elle pour l'éducation
la formation de ses enfants soit
continuer son travail si elle le peut
soit choisir son travail mais alors qu
il faut des moyens de garde pour ses
enfants et le rôle du président de la
république c'est de veiller au
développement et au progrès de chaque
fraction de la société et les femmes
c'est plus de la moitié des français il
c'est un gouvernement qui peut prendre
un certain nombre de mesures
les allocations familiales la première
décision que j'ai demandé au
gouvernement mauroy de prendre c'est et
l'augmentation des allocations
familiales elles ont été de 50% dans
l'année 80 et au total entre 80 et 86 le
pouvoir d'achat des allocations
familiales pour famille de deux enfants
est augmenté de 46%
- pour les mères de trois enfants
18 à 20 % la moyenne 20% et puis
il ya eu la loi roudy dont j'ai déjà
parlé celles qui visent à l'égalité
l'homme et la femme est particulièrement
à l'égalité professionnelle cette loi
était votée en 1983 puis en 1985 j'ai
demandé au gouvernement un bus de
prévoir l'allocation parentale
d'éducation dont on a beaucoup parlé ces
temps-ci qui concerne un bon nombre des
mères de trois enfants à la naissance du
troisième enfant on pense de tout côté a
augmenté ses telle location qui doit
monter en puissance jusqu'à la valeur du
smic
il faut le faire c'est en effet
nécessaire pour l' équilibre familial
enfin il est un domaine que nous n'avons
pas à bord du très important c'est la
situation des femmes seules il y à
quelques 750 mille femmes seules qui
élèvent un million et demi d'enfants
dans quelles conditions dans quelles
circonstances tout ce que nous avons dit
depuis le début notre conversation se
trouve comment dirais-je aggravé pour
les femmes
sun ne gagne pas que les femmes seules
pour lever des enfants
il ya aussi des pères qui sont sales
mais puisque le sujet de notre
conversation porte sur ces femmes je
tiens à attirer l'attention de ceux qui
nous écoutent
alors là il s'agit plutôt de mesures
économiques mais manifestement ce qui
vous intéresse
encore plus c'est l'état d'esprit la
liberté c'est un état d'esprit donner la
liberté à ses fans sur économiques
sociaux mesures sociales ont commeinhes
parler les mesures sociales
lorsque l'on veut parler des écrans
équipements de la garde des enfants
cela est essentiellement sociales nous
aurions dû parler davantage du logement
si le logement n'est pas améliorée
comment voulez vous qu'un père une mère
de famille songe accroître le nombre de
leurs enfants tout cela se tient
vous avez raison de dire il ya aussi une
dimension humaine qu'il ne faut pas
négliger
et je souhaiterais vous en parler à un
moment il vous reste un peu plus d'une
minute pour conclure et bien cette
minute mais servira à vous dire qu'il
faut que les femmes disposent d'une plus
grande distance plus grands moyens dans
le temps et dans l'espace
il faut aussi qu'elles souhaitent en
mesure de s'exprimer davantage dans
notre société
enfin il faut savoir et c'est
l'essentiel que des enfants dans un
foyer
c'est aussi un bonheur responsabilité
mais un bonheur et la france n'a pas
assez d'enfants alors cela regarde aussi
le chef de l'état que d'inciter les
gouvernements et les majorités
parlementaires a décidé par la loi
toutes les mesures qui permettront au
foyer d'avoir ces enfants-là qui seront
des enfants désirés
l'un des objectifs politiques dans le
vrai sens du terme dans le bon sens du
terme de tout responsable de la nation
c'est précisément de parvenir à faire
que la femme soit libre de son choix